The hardware screen space is small
The multidimensional design is encouraged to be enjoyed
Applications are cleaner and easier to view.
But this is difficult for users
Discover all the options your app offers.
I'm Joanna Smith, that's exactly why you should
Take the navigation menu into consideration
The navigation menu is a panel of options
On the left edge of the screen.
They are often hidden.
But can be detected when the user scans from the left.
It is also possible to always be visible
If enough space is available as on tablets
In landscape mode.
Owning a navigation list which
Usually referred to as the left nav, allows your application
By offering a lot of features and behaviors,
Without being visually obscured.
So you can keep your important features in a prominent place
When the user searches for more,
He can use this list.
Now I am fully convinced of your need
To build a left-hand nav.
So let me show you what to do.
First, you must build Drawer Layout.
It must be a root view
It contains two child views
The first child should be a view of the basic content of the screen.
This is when the left nav is hidden,
So when the stairs opens later, it will be in the foreground.
The second child is view from the navigation menu.
After you reach your design
You'll need a list of things to fill.
Navigation view makes this easier
The frame you need for the navigation menu.
You only need to supply a navigation view with a tool
With two things - headerLayout, if you have,
And a list of item names.
The menu is very good indeed
It allows you to populate your content from the XML resource list
Instead of running Show menu programmatically.
Better yet, that means you
Get your multidimensional design on a free nav tray.
This small source can be simple
As a simple set list of selectable elements.
Any item currently selected will be displayed
As a prominent nav element.
However, you can build more complex lists as well
Using sub-headers to group items together.
After you get your list of navigation elements,
You'll need to respond to click events.
You'll get responses to selected items
Place onNavigationItemSelectedListener
Using setNavigationItemSelectedListener
This reply gives you the list of clicked items,
Allowing you to handle selection events
Change selection status, upload new content, and so on.
If it is not a navigation menu
You are always shown in your app, which is very likely,
You'll want to listen to the opening and closing events.
This will allow you to make the adjustments you need before changing the display.
The scan from the left is the default tester
Opens the navigation menu.
But you can also use the hamburger icon
To open and close the tray.
Now there is a final note.
I was referring to the navigation menu
The left nav b, but that does not mean
It must always be on the left.
If your app supports right-to-left layouts, for example
You have learned your layout with start and end attributes instead of left and right attributes
The system will build the right-hand nav instead of the left.
Thus, right-to-left users will be able to scan from the left to open the navigation menu
It will be perfectly aligned with the right side of the screen.
To learn more about Android dev and to ensure that
At your best, take a look at the rest
The contents of our Android development styles are thought to be adhering to
Community + G for tips, tricks and help.
But more importantly, continue to build better applications.